time now for another invigorating
edition of CBS morning's deals where we
share items that might help make your
day a little bit brighter a little bit
better all at exclusive discounts to
start shopping now scan the QR code on
your screen there it is upper left or
visit cbsdeals.com Candy Carter Chief
content officer of the e-commerce
company knocking joins us now candy okay
we gotta go we gotta go I'm gonna make
you a hero in your house okay we are
talking about mops it's called the wow
wow
what it's called come on over here Tony
look at that you pull this back the
lights come on you hit the button look
at that it does the mopping for you here
spray look at that bam
[Music]
you can take the pads off you can wash
them use it over and over again amazing
they also had an announcement candy
though wow
wow that's a wow let me tell you no more
lugging buckets dirty water all day long
okay set it up what's the what's the
brand name look at that Nelly oh Nelly
wow okay every time you say it all right
he here this is a spray that helps with
deodorizing odors your kids your kids
all their sports equipment you can make
it table salt water Shake It Up Put it
on here 16 minutes electrolyze water
okay natural here we go right here 100
to 199 47 off all day long I love it
Game Changer all right these are Tiki
tones this is one of our best selling
products this is the pros of speakers
yes but check this out upgraded high
quality speaker okay handle you can drop
in your bag go to the beach the light is
beautiful you don't have kids knocking
over your real tiki torches here's the
big thing a hundred of them you can sink
a hundred of these oh wow hello
Father's Day graduation parties get at
least four or five of these they're
44.99 they're usually 80 because it's a
really good speaker it has surround
sound Imagine music you could play Candy
uh oh wait a minute I have to play the
music 44.99
we got it okay
that is my move we love it 44 off okay
Gail this is you all day long seriously
okay so this is the thing you have
you're going to a concert going to a
concert a party whatever you have your
crossbody but your phone doesn't fit
right all fits in here put the phone in
you put your license here you put your
cards in here goes across about it so
I'm taking my kids to a concert Bryson
tiller yeah we're gonna have this look
throw your hands in the air like okay
this is you at Bruno Mars all day you
can take your selfies take your pictures
use your Apple pay talk on the phone and
shout out to the airport airport
traveling internationally you can't get
pickpocketed like that 19.99 under 20
bucks amazing get a bunch of these you
like the which color the pink the pink
one yes love it that might find its way
into my purse all day I'm excited about
this because this may surprise you but
my feet are not my best feature okay
I got everything it's not pretty guess
what me too we don't bounce out of bed
anymore right you're like so look all
right
well think less of me but my feet are
not my best okay go ahead rub it rub
your feet like this loosen up those
muscles soak in warm water put the
charcoal scrub on scrub that toe jam oh
you have anything for callus remover
well apparently this is super helpful we
have 30 seconds we have to hurry all
right then you rub this off put this
delicious smelling smell that can you
even put that on your your feet feel
like butter best part you put your toe
separator on it stretches the foot so it
is listen why do I want to stretch this
because because you're always wearing
those heels
okay roll out those muscles do and then
stretch your foot forty dollars 31 off
normally 60 bucks right that's what a
pedicure costs but you can do this over
and over so I should just take all of
these things yes and listen you need
your you need your feet cute for the
summer okay
Carter thank you very much of course we
do partner with all these companies to
get the deals you just heard about to
buy anything I do like flip-flops scan
the QR code on your screen or head to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now you
know you want to